wimy vers Chad is shaping up to be an
alltime Rookie of the Year race but it's
not just about the award these young
stars are the future of the NBA and more
ways than one you don't often see guys
with their build and combination of
length skill and defensive ability this
early in their careers even KD was
wilded by wm's uniqueness he a different
man he different he long athletic he
mobile he can shooting and Chad had a
rookie record seven blocks in one game
all while shooting nearly 50 50 90 we
seen glimpses from some of the best big
men across NBA history it's just these
guys are clearly different but their
rivalry is what makes their match up so
much better let's go back to the
preseason where wimy would get a bucket
on chat and then flexed on him wiy used
his head to get the best of chat leading
Chad to take a jab at wm's Unstoppable
move but it's clear that these guys are
fiery competitors who will bring out the
best in one another setting the stage
for their first official matchup and
hopefully many postseason matchups in
the future